[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de france 24
dimanche prochain le 24 avril aura lieu
le second tour de la présidentielle en
france emmanuel macron de marine le pen
l'affiché la même qu'en 2017 se sont à
nouveau de programmes radicalement
opposé deux visions du monde qui
s'affrontent mais l'issue du scrutin
s'annonce cette fois beaucoup plus
incertaine cinq ans après alors que les
partis traditionnels continuité emmanuel
macron est toujours donné gagnant selon
les derniers sondages mais l'écart s'est
resserré entre le candidat désormais
président sortant est la candidate
d'extrême droite le front anti macron
sur lequel comptent jouer marine le pen
pourra-t-il être plus fort que le front
républicain
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon le
candidat d'extrême gauche arrivé
troisième au premier tour avec plus de
20% des voix sont ils la clé de ce
scrutin sur quels sujets les finalistes
peuvent faire la différence dans cette
dernière ligne droite le débat de
mercredi sera-t-il décisif on va en
débattre avec nos invités ce soir
dominique de montvalon éditorialiste
politique bonsoir benjamin moret morel
en plateau également politologue maître
de conférences à paris ii panthéon assas
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et puis par skype depuis bordeaux jean
petaux politologue
merci à tous les trois j'aimerais
d'abord qu'on regarde un sujet pour
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières heures alors qu'on entre dans
cette dernière ligne droite je le disais
marine le pen était en normandie ce
lundi et puis vous allez voir qu'on
assiste à pas mal de revirements dans
les deux camps ces derniers jours pour
tenter de séduire les indécis mais
surtout les électeurs de gauche au
regard des missions convainc voilà
comment les équipes de marine le pen ont
présenté le déplacement de la candidate
ce matin dans cette commune du calvados
elle est pourtant arrivé largement en
tête au premier tour
[Applaudissements]
sauf que pour espérer l'emporter
dimanche la candidate du fn doit élargir
son électorat et notamment tenter de
séduire les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon pour cela une stratégie
infléchir notamment sa position sur
l'interdiction du port du voile depuis
la rencontre avec une musulmane vendredi
dans le vaucluse elle parle désormais
d'une tolérance pour les femmes âgées
je suis pas insensible mois au discours
de cette vieille dame dont le fils s'est
battu pour la france et qui me dit mais
moi je le pense parce que je suis une
personne âgée et que ça n'a pas la même
signification pour moi que les fusionne
femmes qui sont obligées de le mettre
sous la pression sociale samedi à
marseille emmanuel macron à lui tenté de
verdir son image le président candidat a
même fait sienne l'expression de jean
luc mélenchon de planification
écologique pour les lieutenants dans
marche emmanuel macron a pris en compte
les résultats du premier tour on veut
aller plus loin et plus fort c'est ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
c'est ce qu'attendent les français c'est
ce qu'attend le monde aussi si marine le
pen est élue on serait le premier pays
on serait le seul pays au monde dans
l'accord de paris a arrêté les énergies
renouvelables et même à retirer nos
énergies renouvelables les candidats
devraient désormais limiter leurs
déplacements jusqu'à mercredi soir pour
se concentrer sur le débat décisif de
l'entre-deux tours et puis selon le
dernier sondage ipsos autres à steria
emmanuel macron l'emporterait avec 56%
des voix dimanche prochain contre 44%
vous le voyez pour marine le pen alors
clairement l'écart est plus faible qu'en
2010 est cette fois même si emmanuel
macron a repris un peu d'avancé ces
derniers jours dominique de montvalon on
pourrait avoir une surprise dimanche
oui oui indiscutablement
emmanuel macron et
se présentent à la proche du scrutin du
second tour en favori mais méfions-nous
des sondages en général et je vais pas
en cause l'utilité les sondages les ai
pratiqués comme journaliste pendant si
longtemps mais méfions-nous des sondages
en général et spécialement dans une
situation qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
où le sol politique est incertain bouge
ou les où vous avez énormément de
d'électeurs sincère et pas et
qu'ils n'essayent pas de biaiser qui
disent j'hésite je sais pas je me pose
des questions etc non il ya s'est pas
jouée benjamin morel s'est pas joué
dimanche le taux de participation est
attendue à 72% selon ce même sondage
ipsos oprah steria la participation
c'est ce sera une des clés de ce scrutin
dimanche c'est en effet les que la clé
parce qu'en réalité on voit qu'on a des
enquêtes qui sont quand même moins serré
qu'il ya quelques semaines et que très
clairement aujourd'hui vous on n'est
plus tout à fait dans la marge d'erreur
en tout cas on est sûr sur un écart
beaucoup plus grand mais on sait que les
enquêtes d'opinion on a eu un vrai
problème lors des derniers scrutins sur
l'évaluation de la participation
or il faut voir que lorsque vous avez
une élection relativement serré avec un
taux d'abstention relativement important
celui qui l'emportent c'est pas celui
qui a le plus large électorat c'est
celui qui arrive le mieux à mobiliser
son électorat potentiel est là on a
plusieurs inconnues on ne sait pas
exactement comment va se mobiliser
l'électorat de gauche est-ce que cet
électorat de gauche et bien va se
mobiliser pour emmanuel macron est ce qu
une grande partie va se jeter dans
l'abstention voit que le vote le pen y
est marginal et malgré tout il y a des
velléités abstentionnistes de l'autre
côté à l'électorat populaire qui vient
notamment en secours de marine le pen et
cet électorat populaire il ne s'est pas
entièrement mobilisé pour le premier
tour et une partie peut être jeté dans
l'abstention au contraire se remobiliser
pour marine le pen ça on a aujourd'hui
du mal à l'évaluer et s'il ya en effet
une possibilité qui sont dachau a
démenti ce sera probablement là dessus
sur cette participation différentiel
jean petaux rien n'est joué pour
dimanche d'autant que cette année
marine le pen elle a plus de réserves de
voix qu'en 2010 est
incontestablement ne serait ce que par
la présence d'eric zemmour au premier
tour
ce qui
peut l'amener à espérer récupérer une
partie des voix de zemmour ce qui ne
s'est jamais produit pour un le pen si
je puis dire le père ou la fille
antérieurement puisque il ya cinq ans il
y avait le maigre apport de dupont
aignan qui était venu en quelque sorte
se faire rembourser sa campagne au
guichet du rassemblement national et qui
avait demandé à voter pour elle mais ça
ça faisait pas forcément un report de
voix avec une masse critique alors
évidemment que tous les électeurs qui
ont voté pour eric zemmour ne vont pas
se reporter en masse sur marine le pen
mais elle a potentiellement et c'est
nouveau effectivement un report de voix
et puis c'est vrai que je confirme
complètement le pignon de
dominique mon ballon et de monsieur
morel pour dire que
rien n'est joué effectivement doutant
que ce qu'on a aussi constaté c'est que
les sondages ne peuvent avoir ce qu'on
appelle une dimension de prophéties auto
réalisatrices en quelque sorte puisque
soit il indique que la messe est dite
comme on dit les jeux sont faits et ça
peut provoquer une démobilisation
du côté de l'électorat du gagnant soit
il
incite au contraire ceux qui ne
voulaient pas se mobiliser à un
rejoindre
la personne qui est en deuxième position
au 2ème tour dans les estimations donc
les sondages joue un rôle
incontestablement et tout ça c'est à
prendre en compte effectivement pour
dimanche prochain les sondages qui ont
souvent été
démentie on l'a vu notamment avec le
bric site
outre manche ou encore avec l'élection
de donald trump aux etats unis
les sondages reste aujourd'hui
un marqueur clé qui n'est pas utile doit
pas être unique et claire mais les
beaucoup d'électeurs on a pris 6 me
permettre à jouer avec les sondages à
les lire a annoncé des intentions et
ensuite à ne pas être forcément au
rendez-vous des intentions qu'ils
avaient qu'ils avaient annoncé un temps
moi ce n'est pas une méfiance vis-à-vis
du principe du sondage mais dans le cas
précis spécialement j'y reviens dans une
situation comme celle de la france
aujourd'hui france divisée france dans
les deux pôles cris la structure est
depuis presque quarante ans le ps d'un
côté et la droite républicaine de
l'autre son café -2 5% sont entrés en
très mauvais état et je suis modéré
méfions-nous et sachons que les repères
habituels qui nous permettait de
d'analyser une situation politique aussi
près des scrutins ses repères sont
branlantes sont sains et saufs la geôle
ans on ne sont plus aussi sûrs qu'avant
donc
au minimum
prudence et et benjamin morel vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure il ya une
grande inconnue aussi cccc le vote de
dimanche des électeurs de gauche
notamment ceux qui ont voté pour jean
luc mélenchon au premier tour ils se
sont prononcés en tout cas les militants
de la france a soumis ce week-end en
majorité pour le vote blanc plus de 37%
est-ce que c'est étonnant est ce que ce
vote blanc pourrait favoriser un
candidat ou un autre alors pour
l'instant quand vous prenez les enquêtes
vous avez et ça change parce que il ya
encore quelques semaines on était sur un
tiers un tiers un tiers un tiers macron
un tiers le pen un tir abstention
l'année plutôt sur 40% macron 40%
abstention et 20% le pen dans les
enquêtes d'opinion donc ce qui est ce
cas présentaient les filles n'est pas un
sondage d'opinion c'est une consultation
des militants pour déterminer la
position qui était celle de la formation
politique donc il faut pas tout à fait
confondre tout de même mais aujourd'hui
en réalité vous avez plusieurs types
d'électorat mélenchon et si on veut
comprendre comment se répartit ce vote
il faut aucun en moins trois types vous
avez d'un côté un électorat plutôt
populaire avec une forte porosité avec
le vote est reine on l'a vu en 2017 on
le boit encore aujourd'hui ce sont les
20% qui peuvent éventuellement basculer
jusqu'à 30 40 % j'aime le présent à est
prêt pour l'instant de marine mais
encore une fois quand vous regardez les
enquêtes il ya quelques semaines ça peut
monter un peu plus de l'autre côté vous
avez un électorat qui est plutôt issus
des centre-villes qu'un électorat qui
aurait pu voter élevé qui aurait pu
voter ps mais qui a voté utile jean luc
mélenchon parce qu'il apparaissait comme
étant le seul candidat de gauche capable
de se qualifier pour le second tour cet
électorat plutôt acquis et emmanuel
macron on sait qu'il va se replier très
massivement sur un vote pas gros second
tour ensuite vous avez un électorat qui
est plutôt issus des quartiers
difficiles des banlieues etc est ce cet
électorat là a priori ne va pas voter le
pen mais est fortement abstentionnistes
est la question qui va se poser c'est
est-ce que cet électorat va décider se
réfugient dans l'abstention est là la
polémique sur le voile et cetera va
avoir une importance ou est-ce qu'au
contraire ils veulent se mobiliser pour
emmanuel macron ils s'étaient mobilisés
un petit peu mais malgré tout de manière
significative en 2017 il n'est pas
certain qu'ils soient au rendez-vous des
ions de cette fois ci jean luc mélenchon
a dit dès le soir du premier tour de ne
pas donner une seule voix à marine le
pen mais il n'a pas non plus appelé à
avorter pour emmanuel macron va
l'écouter tout de suite vous ne devez
pas donner une voix à madame le pen
alors je le fais bien
je répète parce que des fois il arrive
que même quand je dis les choses c'est
comme si je les avais pas dit
alors je recommence à cet endroit du
film il ne faut pas donner ça le voir
madame le pen
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame lopez
jean petaux il a été plus clair qu'en
2017 jean luc mélenchon il a appelé à ne
pas voter marine le pen donc de manière
très explicite mais il n'appelle pas non
plus à voter pour emmanuel macron il n'y
a plus de front républicain à gauche
aujourd'hui non mais il n'avait pas déjà
il n'avait pas appelé à voter pour
emmanuel macron il ya cinq ans il
d'ailleurs souvenons nous qu'il ya cinq
ans à la même heure quand il prend la
parole d'ailleurs c'est un peu plus tard
il ya cinq ans au soir du premier tour
il est plutôt dans la contestation des
estimations sortie des urnes plutôt que
dans la déclaration qu'il a pu faire
dimanche dernier ce qui est certain
c'est que
l'électorat mélenchon
dans un premier temps je pense a
montré une vraie réticence à se reporter
sur macron autrement dit affaires
reconstituer une forme de danty l'open
ou de front républicain comme on a
tendance à le dire ce qu'on a constaté
ce qu'on constate maintenant c'est que
les choses semblent évoluer plus vert
effectivement soit un vote blanc soit 1
votre mac rompt avec une partie quand
même un cinquième quand même un qui
comme l'a dit d'un général marc rey un
intérêt pour marine le pen il ya cinq
ans cette proportion était quand même
bien plus faible a été de 7% réellement
mesuré dans les sondages sortie des
urnes du deuxième tour mais je voudrais
un pointer un autre notre partie de
l'électorat dont on parle peu parce que
c'est un peu normal les observateurs se
concentre sur les 7 millions précisément
six cent mille voix de de jean luc
mélenchon c'est à dire les 21 95% des
suffrages exprimés vous avez quand même
entre jadot roussel et
anne hidalgo même si évidemment leur
score a été quand même bien plus faible
tous les trois en dessous 5% que ça fait
quand même un potentiel de 3 millions
500 mille voix qui se sont exprimées
pour ces trois candidats dont on peut
dire qu'une certaine façon que eux sont
les cet électorat est sans doute plus
soucieux de faire obstacle à marine le
pen un très nettement et très clairement
en tous les cas dans une expression
électorale parce que pour le coup les
trois candidats jadot roussel et et
hidalgo ont sans doute été plus plus
ferme dans l'or non seulement leur refus
de marine le pen mais leur manifestation
à voter emmanuel macron même si c'est on
va dire avec ta critique qui est assorti
alors votre grille et il ya quand même
là un potentiel électoral qui est pas du
tout négligeable
en terme de deux repas même partiel pour
emmanuel macron et en même temps
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que l'anti
macro nisme dans certaines catégories de
la population est devenu plus fort que
cette idée de tout sauf l'extrême droite
ce qu'on appellait à ce qu'on appelle le
front républicain qui s'est mis en place
en 2002 on s'en souvient lorsque jean
marie le pen s'est retrouvé au deuxième
tour face à jacques chirac oui c'est une
donne 2022 qui vit qui vient de loin
faits qui datent de doute deux ou trois
ans et qui est qui s'accentue il y a une
une fièvre anti macron personnel et
comment il explique ça c est
moi je moi je serai alors il ya
plusieurs raisons je voudrais insister
sur un point le style macron la façon
perçu très souvent comme arrogante dont
il dit fait parfois des choses vraies de
mon point de vue mais arrogante
l'alleud la façon dont il exigera
exercer le pouvoir en ayant des
réussites incontestables par exemple la
baisse du chômage est impressionnante à
la fin de son quinquennat mais solitaire
l'exercice solitaire de du pouvoir ces
éléments se sont parlé au début de son
mandat
dans président jupitérien oui on est
passé oui on peut aussi dire ça mais
ça lui a permis de débloquer certaines
situations ou de tenir enfin on peut le
soutenir comme on peut le vivre comme ça
et de tenir et d'aboutir dans des
situations de conflits actuels ou tendu
à l'extrême mais bon je reviens à votre
question il ya un phénomène
personnel macron qui est très étonnant
et le prouve la question dispose là
c'est de savoir si ce qui naturellement
en fonction de leurs racines de leur
ancrage politique de leur engagement
passé aujourd'hui ne devrait pas donner
passivement au activement un soutien
quelconque à marine le pen ont fait
repasser devant le lan team acronis mme
ou parce que ils les exaspère parce que
c'est pas possible parce que ne partage
pas le pouvoir
ou s'ils vont revenir à leurs
fondamentaux alors si on prend les tout
derniers sondages répète qu'il faut les
prendre et à mes yeux avec prudence mais
c'est toujours intéressant il semblerait
qu'on revienne quand même à l'ancrage de
gauche à et quand on est
traditionnellement un classiquement de
gauche on ne va pas voter pour marine le
pen mais bon moi je le sers ça comme
journaliste je ne dicte je ne je ne fais
pas de prédiction et je ne dicte de
conduite à personne comment expliquer ça
benjamin morel ce rejet des manuels
macro rejette qui est très fort après
cinq ans d'exercice du pouvoir c'est
quoi c'est sa manière de gouverner ou la
partie je dirais qu'il ya 3 et le
premier aspect c'est en effet des traits
de personnalité comprenait les enquêtes
d'opinion ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir pas seulement l'école de
popularité mais les traits de
personnalité on a un président qui est
apparue orgueilleux hors-sol déconnecté
et méprisant et à partir de là vous avez
en effet je rejoins ce qui a été dit une
forme d'animosité personnelle qu'on a
connus pour nicolas sarkozy qu'on n'est
pas forcément connus comme tels pour
françois hollande et qui est très très
marquante sur la paix sur la figure d'
emmanuel macron qui est un président à
la fois assez populaires 41 % ce qui est
plutôt bien en fin de mandat mais
extrêmement clivant le deuxième aspect
il est social on n'a jamais vu
aujourd'hui une telle stratification
sociale du vote
monter dans l'échelle de revenus vous
avez de chance de voter macron plus vous
descendez vous avez de chance de voter
le pen ce qui crée du coup et bien un
sentiment de vote de classe un petit peu
qui aujourd'hui est très très marquant
notamment dans l'électorat populaire le
troisième élément c'est que et bien
l'animosité vis-à-vis d'un homme
politique ou le refus d'un homme
politique est très liée aux contrastes
en réalité or aujourd'hui l'adversaire
fait beaucoup moins peur on voit une
normalisation de la figure de marine le
pen qui est très très clair très très
forte avec en réalité aujourd'hui un
taux de rejet de marine le pen qui est
dans certaines enquêtes à peu près
équivalent à celui d' emmanuel macron si
l'adversaire fait moins peur et bien
tout d'un coup vous faites moi en vie et
à partir de là eh bien vous avez tout
d'un coup et bien une animosité qui se
cristallisent contre vous qui est tout
aussi importante et jean petaux elle
s'est adouci l'image de marine le pen
voilà incontestablement progressé dans
une dans une volonté j'allais dire
d'apparaître comme à la fois crédible
pour assumer la fonction présidentielle
et puis aussi elle a bénéficié et ça
c'était pas forcément écrit un a
bénéficié de la candidature zemmour qui
a eu un effet évident il l'a des
extraits miser quelques pas il a
recentré compte tenu du fait que elles
pouvaient ainsi trouver et montré
qu'elles avaient plus à droite qu'elle
dans dans la file de droite si je puis
dire un sur la la la haine qu inspire
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il faut
aussi un peu revenir en arrière dans
dans lé président de la république il ya
eu comme des présidentes qui ont inspiré
des haines terrible bon jusqu'à preuve
du contraire il n'y a pas eu cette
tentative d'attentât
qui ont manqué de peu emmanuel macron il
ya plein d'humour gifle oui heureusement
mais peut-être une fille il a fait la
guerre d'algérie rappelé l'homme quand
même monsieur je rappelle je rappelle
que c'était la guerre d'algérie que ça
concernait le général de gaulle mais il
ya eu effectivement une haine féroce
terrible à l'égard du général de gaulle
et et pour françois mitterrand
rappelons-nous alors ce n'était
peut-être pas de la haine mais mais il y
avait quand même une concentration des
tirs contre mitterrand lui même y
compris d'ailleurs un certain moment sur
sa maladie
même si les choses se sont comment dire
calme et on va dire avec le deuxième
mandat mais faut quand même pas oublier
non plus et benjamin morel a eu raison
de rappeler quand même les indices de
popularité
le dernier sondage publié par le journal
du dimanche hier montre un emmanuel
macron avec une remarquable stabilité de
sa cote de popularité à ne pas confondre
avec des intentions de vote nous sommes
bien d'accord mais c'est sans doute un
niveaux les plus élevés d'autant qu'il
faut quand même aussi rappelé que si
manuel macron réussi à ré à se réunir
dimanche soir prochain ça sera le
premier président de la république sans
précédent à la voile à être réélu en
dehors et mais bien des deux qui sont
passés par entre guillemets l'homme
habitait seule la lessiveuse de la
cohabitation qui leur a permis de se
refaire une santé politique aussi bien
entre 86 et 88 pour françois mitterrand
contre 97 et 2002 pour pour jacques
chirac donc c'est tout à fait quand même
une situation
exceptionnelle aussi qu'il faut bien
avoir en tête j'aimerais qu'on vienne de
mini modèles ont voulu réagir non je
partage tout à fait l'analyse qui vient
d'être faite quelque part rang en
durcissant le trait et macron est autant
adulé par les siens qu'il est haï par le
reste des français mais c'est un niveau
de clivage qui évidemment pose problème
j'aimerais qu'on revienne un petit peu
sur ce front républicain
on en parlait tout à l'heure fort
républicain qui nourrit aussi un
discours anti système au rassemblement
national il ya eu les soutiens de
certains chefs d'entreprise à emmanuel
macron du monde de la culture aussi
ça peut irriter certains c'est son tir
ils ne sont pas forcément bon
en effet hérité c'est à dire que la très
clairement on dirait qu'on n'a pas
vraiment eu
je dirais tirer les leçons du braque
site où l'élection donald trump vous
avez aujourd'hui toute une partie de
l'électorat qui se sont jetés évoqué
tout à l'heure et stratification sociale
du vote qui se sent en situation de
relégation donc l'apport de soutien
diverses on va dire à la fois du du
monde politique mais également du monde
culturel risque risque de cristalliser
justement une opposition on a vu ça dans
les enquêtes tout au cours du
quinquennat et on a vu ça au moment de
la crise des jus des jeunes on a vu ça
au moment également de la crise qu vide
vous avez des espaces politiques qui
sont des espaces politiques anti système
qu'est ce qui arrive à marine le pen aux
élections régionales et départementales
effet plutôt un mauvais score d'ailleurs
le et rennes ne gagne aucune région
alors combien prévoyez 2,3 en réalité
une grande partie de son électorat ne
s'est pas mobilisée ne s'est pas
mobilisée par ce qu'ils voyaient marine
le pen comme étant est bien trop
normalisée et donc paradoxalement pour
cet électorat notamment une partie de
lectorat zemmour une partie de
l'électorat qui s'est jetée dans
l'abstention est bien une forme de je
dirais de front commun contre marine le
pen eh bien peut amener au contraire à
rendre ce vote plus enviable d'un côté
vous avez une marine le pen qui fait une
campagne de second tour on va dire dans
justement la lignée de normalisation qui
tentent d'être maire de fleury oui c'est
ça qui tentent d'être beaucoup plus je
dirais lisse et ça lui permet de ne pas
effrayer les lecteurs mais si de l'autre
côté vous avez un monde politique qui
l'attaquent sur la diabolisation
ça peut permettre de mobiliser un autre
électorat donc là il peut lui permettre
finalement d'engranger des soutiens
exactement il n'est pas sûr que ce soit
une bonne stratégie pour la contrer vous
avez évoqué ces sujets du de campagne on
a parlé du voile notamment il ya aussi
les retraites le sujet qui revenue sur
le devant de la scène la semaine
dernière également le pouvoir d'achat ou
encore l'écologie finalement dominique
de montvalon c'est sûr ça c'est sur ces
sujets que ça se joue cette élection on
a parlé juste avant des questions de
personne j'ai le sentiment que je ne
skie pas votre question mais que ça va
ça va compter les questions de personnes
qu'est ce que je pense les lecteurs se
disant qu'est ce que je pense de ce 2
c'est emmanuel macron et en face qu'est
ce que je pense d'eux de la fille de
jean-marie le pen ça c'est le système
présidentiel c'est le système électoral
salut mais dans le cas précis ça me
paraît pas bon ça me paraît en tout cas
très fort et peut-être plus aigus
comment bien des circonstances qu'on a
connu alors effectivement on a parlé
d'une campagne qui a été courte et qui a
réussi aurait eu tendance se disent
beaucoup à esquiver les vrais sujets les
problèmes centraux ils ont fini ils ont
finit par surgir de façon ils ont finit
par surgir de façon limitée trop limité
l'affrontement naval on va attendre le
débat la télévision entre deux ça risque
de entre les deux candidats est
intéressant mais effectivement il ya
quand même sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'écologie et ce il est aussi sur la
sécurité y ont pas ce qui s'est dit au
tout début sur la sécurité sur
l'immigration etc
s'était éclatées
s'était pas toujours très claires serais
tu es mieux pour l'ensemble des français
qui est de la clarté et de la nette et
mais les sujets sont venus finalement
les sujets sont venus éparpillés mais
ils sont ils sont quand même venus
m'enfin au total du total il faut le
dire on vit une campagne électorale en
2022 et c'est pas fini il va se passer
des choses après les législatives et
absolument sans précédent je ne sais pas
je ne vois pas à quoi on peut
comparer ce que nous vivons depuis
georges il ya plusieurs semaines dans
l'histoire politique
la licence de campagne électorale donc
apparaître notamment par la guerre en
ukraine qui était éclipsé pas que par la
guerre en ukraine par l'aco vide
également installés pour le rire où on a
eu une petite période de précampagne
mois d'octobre novembre avec le
phénomène eric zemmour ensuite on a eu
les clips sco vide ensuite une éclipse
ukraine ce qui a entraîné une forme de
dépolitisation de lectorat et en même
temps ce qui a rendu cet électorat
beaucoup plus fluide on a beaucoup parlé
dans la précampagne des indécis
acceptera mais il faut parler justement
de cette singularité de la campagne et
de la désaffiliation politique des
français vous avez environ 20% des
français aujourd'hui qui se disent de
gauche 35 % qui se disent de droite le
reste est très fluide en réalité donc
sacré en effet une double
imprévisibilité jean petaux il est très
fluide aujourd'hui cet électorat c'est
inédit cette élection comme le disait
dominique de montvalon
oui effectivement il ya encore au
chapitre j'allais dire de de l'inédit ou
du presque inédit
c'est la deuxième fois simplement qu' il
va y avoir un débat d'entre deux tours
qui va opposer deux personnes qui se
sont déjà rencontrés
donc ça s'est passé en 74 ans 81 11 on a
même parlé d'un débat allait d'un débat
retour ce qui d'ailleurs mais emmanuel
macron dans une configuration et on
danse à l'arrêt compliqué on va par les
aimez mais on va reparler du débat je
voudrais juste aussi indiqué qu' il y a
quand même une forme de deux paradoxes
dans dans la danse cette élection
présidentielle ou dans ces élections
présidentielles quand on les regarde
j'allais dire un peu en comparaison
c'est que
les propositions
émergent maintenant j'ai dira peut-être
enfin pour cette séquence 2022 avec un
certain nombre de 2 promet zouzou
d'éléments politique qui serait
destinée à voir le jour et à être
concrétisés dans les mois ou dans les
années qui viennent or pas plus tard
qu'il ya quelques jours la banque
mondiale a rendu un rapport s est pas la
seule structure indiquant que la crise
ukrainienne peut prouver va provoquer
une crise économique d'envergure avec
sans doute une chute de 40% du pib d'un
certain nombre de aider des états
occidentaux européens et aux états unis
avec avec très grave menace en
particulier vis-à-vis de l'inflation et
c'est très difficile à à juguler c'est
ce qu'a dit aussi là la directrice
générale du fmi et donc d'une certaine
façon peut-être que tout ce qui s'est
dit alors - sans doute que les autres
fois mais tout ce qui s'est dit pendant
cette campagne peut très bien être
complètement infirmer remis en cause
sous la pression des événements
internationaux
d'ici six mois c'est aussi un petit peu
le paradoxe au moment politique
particulier qui est celui d'une campagne
où tout converge vers les candidats à la
présidentielle quand même à un aspect à
signaler est assez unique je crois dans
des démocraties comparables en europe
benjamin morel vous vouliez réagir oui
non je suis assez d'accord c'est à dire
que vous avez aujourd'hui une campagne
qui s'est fait un petit peu en dehors
des grands enjeux c'est à dire que c'est
le paradoxe on a beaucoup parlé du cren
on a parlé du crâne sur des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux relativement à court
terme ensuite vous avez encore plusieurs
échéances 1 vous avez des élections
effective en juin le monde de juin au vu
de l'instabilité aujourd'hui
géopolitique au vu de l'instabilité
économique ne sera peut-être pas le
monde du mois d'avril et ces
législatives aujourd'hui on en parlait
d'ailleurs un peu tout à l'heure en
coulisses sont très très imprévisibles
c'est la première fois qu'on aurait
depuis la fin du quinquennat une
majorité qui serait reconduite avec le
même président de la république ce
serait la première fois également qu'on
aurait une majorité très peu ont créé si
on part sur l'hypothèse d' emmanuel
macron qui serait également reconduites
fin du cumul des mandats et put et
qu'ils ne viennent pas réellement de du
monde politique c'est très très
compliquées à prévoir donc on peut avoir
une configuration politique très
différente parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que le président de la
république en france a juridiquement
très peu de pouvoir il n'a du pouvoir
que parce qu'il tient de majorité
parlementaire donc on n'a pas fini avec
les élections qu'on pourrait arriver une
cohabitation
on n'en sait rien on va on va attendre
un peu c'est une hypothèse possible mais
je partage tout à fait l'idée que nous
sommes à l'aube ça même commencé d'une
très grande mutation du monde qui va
entraîner des conséquences considérables
et qui peuvent se re c'est un des
aspects des choses remettre en cause
certains des engagements des candidats
d'aujourd'hui qui sont sincères 1 mais
qui ne seront pas en mesure de les
forcément de les tenir et qui sont
obligés de prendre en compte la nouvelle
donne c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas des petites
secousses ou dramatiquement une guerre à
nos portes en ukraine entre l'ukraine et
la russie c'est une énorme mutation dans
50 ans on en parlera comme de une
situation absolument historique
si je puis dire
comparable à la chute du mur de berlin
ça n'a rien à voir mais je veux dire
comme acteur clé de la vie de la vie du
monde j'aimerais qu'on parle à présent
du débat de mercredi
justement on l'a évoqué avant les deux
candidats opposeront leur projet lors de
celui-ci un débat vous allez le voir aux
enjeux multiples on en reparle juste
après
jeudi ils se font face
en ligne de mire
cinq ans après le match retour quelle
est la stratégie de chacun pour
convaincre dans la course vers l'elysée
le débat de 2010 est un traumatisme au
rassemblement national cela ils sont
dans les camps prestation dans les
vallées pour marine le pen
emmanuel macron avait pris l'ascendant
2d pas de bêtises vous en dire beaucoup
cette fois-ci changement de méthode elle
était arrivée épuisée là elle va se
mettre au vert 48 heures
on la préserve elle doit se reposer ce
n'est pas une machine c'est un pur sang
de courses affirme son entourage
au programme des débats fictif pour
s'entraîner avec un énarque qui aurait
un profil proche du manuel macron pour
éviter une nouvelle fois le procès en
incompétence
quand on rate un virage on ne fait pas
deux fois la même erreur confie-t-elle
en prime
lui c'est que le duel s'annonce plus
difficile
les gens vont l'a comparé à 2010 c'est
tout le monde va dire qu'elle a
progressé donc ce sera forcément positif
pour elle s'inquiète un ministre
le président-candidat révise aussi notre
argumentaire tout en poursuivant ses
déplacements elle a pris beaucoup de
temps pour s'y préparer 7 et moi j'ai
toujours mené ces ces débats ces
discussions avec beaucoup de sérieux
alors quelle attitude pendant le débat
pour elle pas d'agressivité
mais une frange confrontation si c'est
un moment qui précisément permet de
débattre projet contre projet
d'évoquer son bilan aussi alors oui ce
sera un moment fondamental de la
campagne côté emmanuel macron justement
on anticipe les attaques on va se faire
pilonner sur le bilan on doit la
démasquer sur son projet détricoter son
programme préconise un conseiller et un
proche du candidat le met en garde il
faut éviter toute forme d'arrogance
des candidats très attendue pour ce duel
où tout peut se jouer
alors est ce que ce débat peut changer
la donne
en tout cas il comptera je sais pas
jusqu'à quel point les changeant la
donne y comptera ya un espèce de
paradoxe à d'ailleurs été évoquée dans
le sujet elle ne peut elle
que faire mieux que la fois dernière
parce qu'elle s'était écroulé
complètement au point que d'ailleurs à
droite et à gauche beaucoup pensé qu'on
ne reverrait plus jamais à marine le pen
si on a un peu de mémoire on se rappelle
ce qui avait été dit à l'époque nla elle
semble avoir tiré les leçons style et
peut-être fond de son dérapage
magistrale de 2010 est donc
effectivement la joaillier qui s'étaient
prêtées et le provost était prêt terrain
ministre peu importe mais elle ne peut
faire que mieux aller mieux que la fois
dernière
non seulement il a son bilan à assumer
qu'il assumera emmanuel macron mais il
va falloir qu'ils trouvent un ton
certainement dénuée d'arrogance parce
que ces énoncés se caricaturait il
marquait un but contre son contre ses
propres intérêts mais trouver un ton
pour de son point de vue effectivement
faire valoir co2 au delà de la forme un
puisqu'elle veut être elle veut elle
entend elle aspire à gérer le pays comme
comme une mère de famille et puis elle
est devenue plus rondes plus haut
on sens du terme à un psycho logique
mais au-delà de ça qu'est-ce que son
projet recouvre exactement voilà ça
c'est pas jouer mais au départ la balle
elle est à mon avis dans le camp
d'emmanuel macron c'est à lui de n'ont
pas tiré le premier mais de dire le
premier
de trouver un ton est d'essayer de
l'imposer ll va jouer un peu en dedans
et au départ elle ne peut que marquer
des points et jean petaux il va devoir
trouver un ton emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron qui va devoir la jouer défensif
il doit défendre son bilan il n'est pas
forcément dans la bonne position
oui je la vis ils défient des trop
défensif il peut aussi juger c'est
génial à la meilleure part de du débat
et c'est ce que retiendront les les
aider des électeurs montre les qualités
les spectateurs ce qui est certain c'est
que
pour le coup pour pour ce pays où on
tendance à dire que est une forme de
dépolitisation je crois que ça va
rassembler beaucoup beaucoup de
téléspectateurs parce que parce
qu'effectivement cette dimension
sportive encore une fois et le sujet que
vous avez montré démarré par cette
expression de deux matches retour je
pense que ça ça va passionner les
téléspectateurs il ya une dimension très
très près ce que jeux télévisés ou
concours télévisé qui intéresse je crois
que emmanuel macron a dit qu'il
préparait ce ce débat avec tout le
sérieux qu'il fallait comme un match om
psg 1
manière de faire encore un clin d'oeil à
l'om ce qui est certain c'est que
ça
ce qui va sortir de ce débat peut jeudi
par renverser forcément le résultat 1
d'autant que si les sondages sont un peu
près stabilisé
la marge de sécurité apparaît un peu
pour emmanuel macron on estime
généralement et qui peut y avoir un
déplacement rarement supérieur à 2 %
dans ce genre de
2,2 débat sur un électorat qui est
fluide comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
où on tue les cas instable en tous les
cas c'est vrai que encore une fois
le rôle d' emmanuel macron je pense est
plus compliquée à interpréter que celui
de marine le pen l'a traduit soir marine
le pen si elle va se mettre au vert on
l'a vu dans le sujet pour préparer ce
débat après sa prestation ratée de 2017
est ce que ça peut l'aider oui ça peut
l'aider parce qu'elle a besoin
d'apparaître crédible on a beaucoup
parlé de dédiabolisation de marine le
pen et c'est un élément essentiel pour
arriver à comprendre aujourd'hui
l'élargissement de son électorat vous
avez également la crédibilisation de
marine le pen quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui les enquêtes d'opinion vous
voyez que marine le pen est beaucoup
plus crédible et notamment sur certains
sujets comme le pouvoir d'achat elle est
même parfois plus crédible qu emmanuel
macron elle a un déficit sur certains
aspects l'international d'où les
conférences de presse qu'elle a tenue il
ya quelques jours mais sur ces sujets là
on a un vrai travail de crédibilisation
sur cinq ans
et pourtant en effet à partir du débat
de 2017 et bien le rn partait de très
très loin donc là une chute sur cet
aspect de la crédibilité serait terrible
pour marine le pen si vous regardez
c'est passé en 2017 vous avez un
effondrement sondagier juste après ce
débat que c'était très très mal passé et
ensuite on connaît le résultat mais en
réalité ce n'est pas des électeurs qui
venait de chez marine le pen et qui se
sont dits du jour au lendemain non en
fait je vais voter macron c'est en fait
une démobilisation comme on l'évoqué
tout à l'heure de l'électorat donc si
jamais on n marine le pen qui apparaît
peu crédible une partie de son électorat
et bien décidera que finalement par
faisons forte contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur et plutôt que de voter macron
abstenons nous en revanche si emmanuel
macron c'est est évoquée à paris trop
orgueilleux où apparaît comme étant l'
inverse de ce qui est attendu justement
par ses électeurs de gauche par exemple
mais également parmi une partie de la
base de droite qui l'a conquis par vote
utile sur valérie kress lors du premier
tour mais qui pourrait très bien
également se réfugient dans l'abstention
si jamais une attitude il est conscient
du risque on met bien sûr mais ce que
jamais une attitude conduisait justement
à cristalliser cette image négative qui
peut avoir dans cet électorat il
pourrait percevoir une partie de cet
électorat qui se réfugie dans la presse
qui se réfugient dans l'abstention donc
malgré tout il ya un enjeu ce débat et
ce débat ce sera aussi l'occasion
enfants de discuter des vrais
thématiques 1 notamment le pouvoir
d'achat ou encore les retraites
l'occasion que les deux candidates
défendeurs d'achat lors leurs pertes
l'europe
l'international est de la france aussi
avec une guerre qui s'étend à nos portes
etc c'est vrai rien ne vaut que la
confrontation directe c'est aussi pour
ça que que ce débat n'est pas seulement
un affrontement de psychologie de
posture et de look que bien que ce soit
en partie ça mais c'est aussi quelque
chose de fond qu'est ce que les
téléspectateurs les citoyens en réalité
vont retenir de chacun crédible pas
crédible rassurant pas rassurant
intéressant au sens fort du mot voilà en
jeu j'arrête c'est c'est un rendez-vous
qui que certains feignent pas ici mais
le certains feignent de prendre à la
légère disant je verrai j'ai vu des
reportages je verrai je je le regarderai
je le regarderai pas il y aura beaucoup
de monde devant le poste et chacun se
fera une idée jean petaux est ce qu'un
débat d'entre deux tours à a déjà changé
et quelque chose à à une élection
difficile à dire je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que lorsque la marge est très
très étroite
par exemple ça a été le cas de 1974 où
l'un valéry giscard d'estaing avait
manifestement réussi à prendre le dessus
1 sur françois mitterrand et l' inverse
en 1981 où quelques parle le sort de ce
débat a été été inversés on a pu
considérer que ça va peut s'imposer en
tous les cas dans dans le succès de
giscard en 74 et de et de mitterrand en
81 encore une fois parce que mes skis a
dit benjamin morel est très juste assure
finalement les électeurs qu'ils sont
convaincus ou pas il ya un nom un point
par exemple qui risque d'être un élément
central peut-être dû du débat c'est on
parlait de crédibilité 1 c'est la
crédibilité internationale c'est
véritablement la capacité pour marine le
pen à reprendre le costume si je puis
dire de la chef d'état de la chef des
armées la question des relations avec
l'allemagne par exemple va être vraiment
très importante comme avec la lucienne
pardon oui
marine le pen qui a prôné un
rapprochement stratégique avec moscou
une fois la guerre en ukraine terminée
alors on va on voit mal on verrait mal
emmanuel macron ne pas ne pas utiliser
sept 7 607 position 1 affiché par marine
le pen d'autant que l'on parlait de
crédibilité je termine là dessus
marine le pen a quand même un déficit
d'entourage
il n'y a pas de personnalité j'allais
dire présentable en termes de
crédibilité
gestionnaire un
camp comme
emmanuel macron a d'ailleurs pu dès le
premier tour de 2017 edel avant deuxième
tour de 2017 en faire état 1
même s'il était en dehors des partis
politiques il avait déjà eu des
ralliements avant le deuxième tour je
pense en particulier à bruno le maire et
à d'autres 1 qui lui permettait
d'afficher et puis des et
personnalité socialiste comme le drian
qui était quand même à un ministre de la
défense sortant ce qui n'est pas le cas
du tout de marine le pen a n'a pas de
banc que m'ont dit hein elle n'a pas
d'équipé elle n'a pas de banc un tout
dernier mot benjamin morel et dominique
de montvalon il nous reste une minute si
vous voulez conclure sur les jeux sont
faits non les jeux sont pas tout à fait
fait même si aujourd'hui au vu de l'état
des enquêtes d'opinion il ya en effet je
dirais une indication assez forte mais
pour le coup emmanuel macron n'est pas à
l'abri d'un accident et ceux du coup ce
débat va compter parce qu'en effet vous
avez une campagne d'entre deux tours qui
était une campagne extrêmement dure 1
souvenez-vous gérald darmanin si jamais
emmanuel maxi jamais marine le pen est
élue les pauvres vont mourir et cetera
on a une campagne extrêmement dure et à
partir de là arrivait justement à une
position qui soit une position de
président sortant très présidentiables
qui considère son adversaire sans être
méprisant c'est compliqué donc en effet
il y à des plumes à perdre merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les trois
merci jean petaux qui était un skype
depuis bordeaux merci benjamin morel
merci ou également dominique de
montvalon merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce débat rester avec nous sur
france 24 alain formation continue
[Musique]